[Music]
she's
you need her yeah like she's here for a
reason yeah
she needs you know she's doing this like
as a friend not like a charity thing
you're doing for her yeah
no it's like what happens now when you
go on shows like i did like james corden
or whatever it is you're leaving
he's like uh they're like here's the
elements to put on your
name don't forget like aren't i on your
show
whose show like i thought i was on your
show like he's getting paid 20 million
dollars a year but i have to be
distribute your show i'm yeah i'm your
digital person i'm not getting paid for
this
wild wild um are we going
we're rocking we're starting okay we can
cut anything if you have to get up and
pee we get up and pee
we do post on the show awesome we'll cut
ourselves let's see
y'all are making sure i'm comfortable
that shit is nuts that's what's up
dude is the um air conditioning enough
are you hot cold no i'm crying you can
do a wardrobe
fantastic right now it's called like all
power we have all the power now
love that it's over it's over
do you know what i'm saying that was the
only good thing that came out of
quarantine
it's just it's really like i'm done
traveling i'm done doing this bush
how are y'all i'm just gonna do this i'm
gonna do it in my house
like i don't own a nice camera how do my
people that have talent
have the power we have so much power now
it didn't it was that's not how it was
before it was like i have a bunch of
talent and i have to beg 200 people to
let me put on a play
it's amazing that's what it used to be
yeah i have to get like to beg
but there's something at the very end uh
we'll put on the prompter
on something at the end okay first
things first
i did not know you were gonna fully um
rock out be dressed up uh in full
christmas decorations
i know it's been my whole promo outfit
ugly sweaters it was so good
and i thought i was gonna be super corny
so good and uh give you an option of
which earrings you wanted to wear for
the show
no way either these little christmas
trees
or these ornaments yes
but you this bitch showed up wearing
bows i don't think i can beat it i don't
think you wear those
well which one should i do those
everybody also i wore
this sweater accidentally channeling
like um
christmas christmas in like the hood and
then
prince of bel-air
but i have only two christmas sweaters
that i'm gonna run by you
this is the first one which i got in
nashville cute
which is a vibe bye bye bye say
um she the divorce
didn't go great yes but she's still
ready to dance
she's still ready to dance she's still
got it
all day she does her kegel yes like it's
not over yet
it's not over for her she didn't mingle
is palm okay
love her um the anastasia
shimmering body oil is getting on the
bands
at pilates class okay right
okay see it got it this i don't know
oh shit this is one of these little
nazis
i don't even know what this is that's
like you have seven kittens
in the other room that i never saw
coming in here that i eat
but i'm into that yeah this is a little
german ski slope murderer
yes no yes go with this girl this one
this is
spicy you know i like it why it's a
little dolly
okay a little dolly what do you think
yeah yes a little dog dolly dolly okay i
was like what
dolly parton yes her christmas album
fly just how you fly you're not fake
you just went okay like i knew you
no you can read my face so it's like a
disease i have i can't lie
i can't everyone has plastic surgery i
can't read any of them yes
that's why i only trust young people
because you can actually read their
feelings
yeah i get i tell everything on my face
too how old are you
i i'm 26. i forget
but i'm 26. wow your boobs are
phenomenal thank you
so much they're great i know i heard
but like good job though like worth it
that's my goal that's the only plastic
surgery i want is boobs after i have a
hundred kids
i want these to look up yeah or to
like look like related have your nipples
just be like crocodile eyes
yeah like they i grew up sagging or like
crap
yeah and i never had like awesome huge
boobs like i had
cone boobs forever i had that too and my
brothers were like what's up cone tits
and i was like yo that's the meanest
thing you could ever say
that's so traumatic yeah and then as
soon as they got rounder they were like
well because a lot of times that yeah my
boobs grew up
pointy and they were like traffic cones
yes you know and and there was no um
like fat on the bottom yes my nipple was
very low and i had any nipples
no you did yes i did they were like tiny
no yeah
my little brother has that i thought he
was the only human being no i had any
nipples for a while
shut up what was it like
they never popped out wait when did they
fell when did they pop out the pain from
it
how old were you when they popped what
was the experience that's a great
question i think it was after i went on
a moon bounce
um no but let me say real quick
you i just did this thing called cool
laser
cool laser pool laser it's like a
treatment where they set you on fire
uh so that you produce more collagen
because i'm trying to get ah i'm trying
to get ahead of this
i know it's i know what's in store for
me yes kathy griffin i know i know how
this story ends
so i'm trying to get ahead of it so okay
so do you see all
the little tiny burns on my chest
sure i i hold
you see them you're going to see them
and then oh i see that i knew that would
happen oh you know what that look yeah
those are like lines
they're like lines they're like little
like okay you're looking at freckles
like i guess
stop jerking off you guys yeah yeah a
billion stabs on my tits okay you all
have bonus those are crazy
i know that hurt i think it works you
did it everywhere
but you get to suck a anesthesia
yeah oh that's good they let you suck up
no i'm willing to do all that stuff
you can't do nothing do nothing but the
boob thing is traumatic i used to stuff
my bra
i used to put i did that i used the gel
patches
bitch my father bought me those he goes
happy birthday sweetheart you're
lopsided and i was like
thank you wait from victoria's secret
calling road in pharaoh the jail wait
the gel pad
bought you he's my good friend yeah he
he's the only one to go shopping with
because my mom would be like you look
great in these stripes and i'd be like
why the fuck would you let me buy
stripes
can we swear we can swear but my dad was
like please
don't okay my dad who was like i found
these gels at victoria's secret on his
own went to victoria's secret wait i'm
sorry he's all over there
walked into the police for me the police
didn't get him isn't that what the
security broke
he means so well and then he saw they
had the gel things like
that alone
fbi he that's what he would do
what city was this um cape cad tape i
need to talk about
messages i know we have so much to talk
about
hold on how dare you degrade this piece
of sweatshirt
we
who am i is this appropriation
is her steak and assuming what's
happening um
so it's okay they don't really move that
much they look great so i
go to cape cod with benton ray don't do
that when you that was
that was my first mistake yeah let me
ask you a question when you go to stay
at hotels
do you have a pseudonym am i pronouncing
it right a fake name an alias
yes it was um lizzie mcguire
for like still my whole career still
come find me lizzie mcguire shot i told
her that as soon as i met her
shut up let the rain
fall down you don't know that and make
my dreams
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so keep going hold on do you guys
not know about millie vanilli
oh right you didn't know what the person
you just called
yeah you you're friends with this girl
and you didn't know where big as you
guys
need to know you're playing you don't
have a microphone
you're just gonna say that um you don't
know who millie vanilla is
i know that name oh my god
okay so you youth that we meghan trainor
pop star famous ball
but doesn't know who millie vanilli is
so the one
millie vanilli was a uh a
boy man when i was were they the ones
that weren't actually singing
in the 80s i'm sorry were they the ones
that got caught not actually singing
yes i know them we're friends
you like how you were caught not
actually knowing i was like millie
it was them right dude millie vanilli
was
like before i'm trying to think they lip
synced publicly
somewhere it was like th it was almost
like the first cancellation
yeah it was it was do you think wasn't
it that actually might be the first time
someone got cancelled
but then lip singing became really cool
right after that
they were just alive at the wrong time
they were but also they didn't even like
sing their songs
that's the problem say that again say
that again i think they didn't even sing
though
but say it in a different way it's
something that doesn't understand music
okay i think another human being
performed those songs and they were the
face and said
these are our songs when like britney
spears records her vocal
most of the time and then goes out and
lip syncs to herself
uh-huh so they were lip-syncing to
strangers
they were poppets of a marionette and
that's what
we were all like no no no imagine cancel
i want to hear
i want to see the movie about the guy
that really sang that
i was like you probably love that man
that because that means you're gonna
find someone was like you're too ugly
you should bring him on here and be like
what was it like for you were you a
monster
i'm a v come now we need to know what
your life was like but think about it
because so i'll be pissed so that's how
the music industry used to be it was
like you have a great voice
you're pretty so you're going to sing
and you're going to pretend to sing this
person
it's still devilish but it's what it's
now here they're like you can look
exactly how you are kind of
you know keep god
hold on don't don't don't don't don't
don't you dare
try to are we gonna do mini mini milly
vanilli milly vanilli but this
blame it on the rain i raise you one let
the rain fall down by hillary duff
dude
i know and like the millie vanilla shit
dude it sounds like a ringtone that you
have to wake up to that you don't want
to
okay this is important this is an
important part of music history i'm
going to teach meghan trainor about
music my god he doesn't even know how to
lip sync
the fake horns on the keyboard so trippy
so he's lip syncing someone else yeah
it's probably like
a white boy somewhere i don't know
they're singing though okay so this is
going to get us kicked off
the internet or whatever um no this kill
us
no no we'll put up a thing and we'll
figure it out i would love to get sued
by this
it should be good like the like who is
that guy
the guy living in like in a pool we're
trying to show how awesome he is
do you guys need to borrow money from me
to sue me guys yeah yeah it's gonna be
sad
all of this is sad blame it on the rain
that was a big deal
and it was like it was kind of like the
first break like post-modern
post-modern break in media
because it was like all of a sudden we
saw how the sausage was made
it was like someone else sang a song
yeah they're like what
someone else sang it holy fuck we were
tricks we were tricked by this music
industry
yes hoodwinked us yes
never heard that but that's cool that's
cool
we're going to come back to this because
i want to talk about the smoke and
mirrors of the music business
yes cape cod is where you're from sad
that's so that's such a lie
what's a lie you're not from there i'm
from nantucket island
you caught me did was i right but i went
to high school in cape cod so i get no
but i mean no one's from cape cod right
i'm from nantucket island
what is the point of nantucket rich
white people which
what it's like it's a point for like
let's get out it's for the point for
rich white people to visit
from new york uh-huh like we can't go to
the hamptons this year we must go
tonight
yeah and um when you live there though
it's sad dark and depressing yeah yeah
and it's like you you're just hanging on
to survive there
but what does it make what's its thing
we used to kill whales
cool cool bro so
cool awesome and we're so sorry
they're so proud of it that they still
have the museums
of the bones from the whales that they
stabbed for oil
i hate i mean sorry i know
no no no no no all right don't cancel
but like it's ten thousand people it's
fine it's fine
fuck them they all it does feel like a
fake it's
weird it's a weird and we're the whalers
like we're still the whalers that's what
we're called as a
as a team whales can't play sports right
i mean they can't they're so dark
it's like the darkness lions tigers i
get that whales are like just
your school trip is like let's go see
how we killed whales
and you go to the museum i hate
this dude it's gnarly i didn't know
anything else i didn't know
that like wow i didn't know what malls
were parents
they were um working on the island my
dad was 20 years older than my mom so he
like
had his life ready and she was like i'll
pop out all the kids and then i'll work
with you
yes they were jewelers together on the
island
hot so i just brought you these so by
the way so i'm so insulting by the way
so am i
does your mom great she will use
it's so funny she's that bitch that
makes jewelry never wears she want my
advice
she would love those she's like wow but
she's the girl that's like um this is
made out of plastic a jewelry
yeah they made like that real sturdy
gold
and would sell it to monstrous people
wow like the worst i remember and then
the pirate
when we had to work there i remember
this
like fat rich guy sorry dude with like
plaid
i don't know who he is i don't care he
came in with his son who was
maybe seven maybe six with a full rolex
on full rolex
and they were just coming to glance and
he handed me his credit card that was
like
steel it was like eight pounds like i
was like oh my god
how do i use this and it was like those
kind of people and they're just monsters
and he's like come on son let's go look
at the new rolexes and i was like
what yeah i didn't know what any of this
stuff was
and but where's your parents parent
what's your ancestry how did they get to
nantucket how do you get to nantucket
my mom was from new hampshire and she
was a
okay this is weird so
my dad is 20 years older than my mom yes
you said that my dad's
was my dad was friends with my mom which
they were they
25 when they met how old was she when
they met
she was nice because you keep saying 20
years ago no i don't know because you're
not telling me hold on she has an
uncle who was friends with my dad okay
that's
that was basically just tinder back then
yeah exactly yeah yeah so my uncle's
friend they're like
keep gary away from her and i was like
that sounds dirty that was a lot of
happiness
and she would go visit her uncle back
then
yeah and he was calm down
yeah he used to summer there too and
then he's like i'm going to live here
forever i love it
yeah so he was like 19 years old yeah
yeah he lived a whole lifetime and do
you know your ancestry ancestry
uh great question we mean like like yeah
like where like what's your
lineage i'm we got to do your twenties
i'm british
real that yes i am i'm like all white
and have you been i'm just boring
england when you go to england you feel
like okay that's that feels right
oh london is that what i mean yeah i
belong i make a lot of friends there and
go to the your place of or there's
something happens to you like
like chemistry i've been here before
yeah i know how to do this
it's like because it's like when i go
because i'm mostly
uh western european and when i go to
london i'm like yeah they're cloudy no
sunscreen like yeah this is where i
belong yes
i avoid the sun i don't belong in
california
i stay away from nightmare it's a
nightmare i can't function in a desert i
have sinus infections i need sunscreen
yeah
people outside oh my god that makes
sense yes that's it that's it
but we should find out your um ancestors
yeah i'm like all british
and then like polish and scum yeah i'm
the ashes
no it's this it's pulling my skin up
yeah because you do have the german
these are hats things we just popped
these on this is a whole hat
so this is me but it's pulling me
pulling the life back but thank you so
um this is just a litany of tangents
that's what a podcast is
yes um i said what is your alias and you
said listen mcguire so we called the
bitch
and then uh the point of it was for
those of you listening in aliases like
if you're famous
if you're femmos i'm not famous i'm
notorious
and sick you will put a fake name at the
hotel
yes just so that people aren't like
paparazzi whatever i mean i
stalkers yeah yeah i'm not famous enough
so i should just start putting like
jennifer lawrence down so that
paparazzi is hilarious yeah make it good
i really should just put jennifer lopez
but her alias jennifer lopez's alias is
probably more famous than me
like i feel like photographers
photographers probably know her alias by
now whatever
the point is okay so we go we get in at
what two in the morning
we get there we're like it's called you
got there too
we at two in the morning because we go
to boston and we drive from boston
so i was like i'm trying to it's covered
we're in a pandemic i'm trying to
use the number of cars i'm trying to
reduce the number of hotels so i go
flying to boston we land at midnight we
go straight to a hotel in
cape cod do you know what it's called
benton do you remember was it in
a resort so uh okay so we go to i know
these hotels are spooky dookie dude
they're
spooky as fuck so and they're a thousand
no
so go back this is where you went yeah
so i pull in that's haunted
that's famous as high and so am i so my
ghost they laid here
they're fighting it was a resort that's
the place where if we would give if
we get drunk or something and my mom
would pick us up and drive us home he'd
be like
oh stop don't go there stop we had a
great show in cape cod
we get to cape cod we did a show in cape
cod in cape cod we stayed in brewster
yes okay and so basically we get there
20 am
at 2 a.m and the hotel
room is under walter brown which is me
yes so we go and we check in i'm like
i'm so tired i'm exhausted i'm like
doing instagram stories like just
whatever being jealous of people on
instagram in the corner yes
and then benton i'm like what's
happening why aren't we getting the keys
yes because i had already pre-planned
for all this and i've called ahead
checking no but here's the thing the guy
that worked there john
john john john didn't know who i was
so someone that's not famous having an
alias is
very confusing that's yeah they're like
this is so special giving me my key
and then he goes i need to see her id
and i was like i give her money
it says when he comes and he goes well
this is under walter brown i was like i
know but
but i'm famous but i'm whitney cummings
and he's like
he goes i don't know who you two are
and i know you don't have to know no one
no and then he goes
and he goes well i can't give you this
room what if walter shows up yeah what
if mr brown
shows up oh no and i said we are
just give us the room we are mr brown
and then we went we had to carry our
luggage oh no you're missing the part
where he goes
do you guys know where you're gonna stay
and we went no we've never been here
and he goes okay we're gonna go this way
i'll hold your hand to make sure you get
there
he said that and it didn't no no and
then we walked out and they indeed
you know those like resorts where you
have to like go down like a cement
pathway and then in a door and then an
elevator there's like four flights of
outdoor stairs
haunted we're holding our luggage fully
haunted
and then i decided remember when i said
um i decided it wasn't open
oh yeah she brought him back out and
then she goes is this place
up and running no is there anyone
working here it's not
i can't tell he's getting a beat john
turns and goes no ma'am
i'm the only one here he's probably a
ghost
bro he's dead
he never offered to carry my luggage you
know i put on instagram me carrying my
luggage upstairs because he's a ghost
and his hand would have gone
you would have gone right through it i'm
telling you nobody messes with that
place
so then oh no it gets better down
four flights of stairs we take our
luggage into an empty parking lot where
he goes
well this is where you would have parked
and i said and then what would happen
john where are we going
and then he goes he goes i go we
couldn't find our room i'm sorry this is
he's just guessing our room and then he
goes i go do you know where a room is he
goes i really don't he goes no ma'am i
really don't know how old is he
and then he keeps going out loud 6 40.
out loud keeps going
this is not going well isn't it no good
is it
he kept saying that out loud it's like
this is really not going well
doesn't know where we're going so we
should start looking as a group together
we just start searching like where could
we be
at this point we've abandoned the
luggage it's just in the parking lot
yeah okay we're walking around the
resort oh my god that was
so it was so yes but i think it's
important
that you're from this area yes it is
like that's why when i travel everything
is like
tall buildings and like wow they're
gonna help me with my luggage it's your
face i don't know
that's why i grew up in the village yeah
they think everyone's like oh you're
from nantucket you're rich and bougie
i'm like i've
never been in first class until i was
like like
a number one song like traveling to
australia like i didn't know that
being super wealthy yeah people do
you die because at downtown new york
rich people go
live there on their other days like on
they have their second house out there
but the working class
but the working class yeah we're just
like regular
like people that are trying to pay the
bills that are going to school
and like getting drunk but they're the
most hardcore
salt of the earth we're angry
bold
remember at the show like the um the the
security guard and stuff and this
is a beautiful story about how you saved
her life yeah yeah i love those like
it's just like
like i'm just trying to figure out your
essence i guess it makes you an older
soul
maybe yes you have that and that's why
it's part of your talent
yeah it really got me far my personality
it i'm really serious like you coming
into hollywood like of like a brewster
bitch coming into the
business it's like you can smell
bullshit that's what it is yeah it's
like
it's a take no shit attitude yeah
because you grew up everyone else
yes and everyone is like don't ever
change and that's the one thing my
family's like
you the same girl like and why is that
because the the
the stereotype is you go through the
machine of the music business and they
change you and whatever but you know
like where you grow up from you're like
oh this high school bullshit
i think as i like went to hollywood or
nashville the songwriting community or
la
that community i was like oh this is
just like high school times three like
the award shows i'm like oh this is prom
wow yeah and i was like this is a bunch
of books
so we would go and like make fun of the
night me and my bros be like oh my god
i'm so famous
look at that you know we just like this
is high school with wigs
yeah i mean yeah we're all wearing like
stilts i really needed my glam team at
my real prom but
like how did you know how did you know
all this this is the kind of shit that
you
see when you like sit ayahuasca and
you're able to see everything
yeah i like it's just a new generation
of young people
no no it's some of us who are very rare
i think it's
like how are you how do you see this so
clearly uh i don't know
because i fell for it i fell for the
whole really i fell for it if people do
it's fine it's fine whole clown
intentions
were you alone yes yeah you're alone
yeah have you met
i told my older brother who's a year and
five days older than me like
we're close now i told him drop out of
college i'm going to la and i'm not
going by myself
so he came with me we were just laughing
at everybody and my younger brother's
out with us and they still live with me
to this day
and they're like what are their names uh
ryan and justin nice oh they did this
album
soul mask ryan and justin my thing
they're on this album oh they're on the
back look how cute they are
so that it's different oh that's cute
you don't have to show it off like that
i don't care but look i want you to be
so wrinkly i have all the money
no all the money of all the money these
are my bros can you get me a
piece of duct tape the one that i use in
my hotel room i want you to open up all
the money
i'm banking on this every year to just
pay for it like benjamin just went into
a full
suicidal spot he just quit where's the
time did you just quit in your head when
i asked you to do that today or
thank you i won't be able to put this
here i just thought of it i think having
the two bros
you know wow or your brothers are
younger
uh i'm the middle child wow that's a
cool thing that's a whole
yeah alone that's a whole thing i don't
know a lot of middle children
what what i would love us
y'all are like what's your thing
what's the middle child because you i'm
the best you know like well no
here's no this is what the middle child
the middle child is uh
we just had one we want to have another
one this one didn't go so great we want
another one
we nailed it and then the second one and
the last one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you can just
say your gold
gold medal i'm going i'm the one that
really wanted you know
they they did it for me yes and they
knew how to raise you because they
they fucked up yeah yeah so they like
we're all probably and by the third
everyone's like
they don't really watch that one you
know yeah like he'll be fine yeah yeah
and then they're resilient yeah
and i was the only girl so i'm like the
girl but i was a nightmare
i guess this is working um dave can i
see him yeah hilarious
yup it looks so professional
we don't need you we don't
need the distributors anymore we
got it we got dog tape so yeah we're i'm
a big family person
all my albums they do all my songs with
me this one they literally
did it should happen in your family no
of course there's like some demons in
your family but like
um my parents i'm so lucky dude i swear
because my parents are so solid and like
great to us and like are still married
or something
that my career is like awesome because
of them
and i see my friends who are so talented
parents are married awesome yeah
still that's right i know i like that
sounds hard it's long
it's like it's like are you both okay
yeah but then they're like they stay in
the same house
shocking there's like yeah there's
obviously times are you okay
i'm okay i'm like my mom she's just like
a saint
she's one of those like her name kelly
[Applause]
she's like the most selfless little
angel ever doesn't want to take a
picture
hates cameras like the cutest what were
the um like awkward growing pains of you
getting famous with them
was there my mom having to be
interviewed and like radio station would
be like let's call your mom and
prank her and i'm like okay she's gonna
hate this
but there was no like no shadows came
out no
i i just shadows well my dad was married
to
twice before her so i'm waiting for my
um
other sisters to come to come out and
say hit my legs all over my chin uh
no but benton is a makeup artist so
he'll tell you exactly i think you look
beautiful thank you you look perfect
um yeah my i thank you i'm like yeah
is that your is that did you explain her
to do that to me
is that part of the media training
about your gorgeous perfect face that's
what makes people like oh my gosh
we have to have flaws now that's the
whole thing and that's what i'm fucking
like caked on today
i was like you just got a lot so you
could have stretch marks you could get
likes i know
oh my gosh women literally just have
babies no i'm going to bejewel them like
everyone's wearing
like i'm going to go get plastic surgery
to get stretch marks
yes i'm going to go get flaws because
that's what people are into now
well you get more likes it's cool um
dave can i see them on her
yes my dad was married twice that's okay
before he had two whole lives that we
don't even get to talk about we don't
know
so i'm like where are my siblings um
yeah they haven't popped out yet though
that's good it's awesome but you didn't
marry one of them so that's okay i
didn't marry my brother
that was my that was my big oh i look
awesome there we go here we go look this
is good that's so nice you put that on
for me no yeah
i just that's for you and this is i just
wanted to make sure
um because i have some illegitimate
brothers and sisters running around
do you really yeah oh what's it like are
you okay
uh what do you think no you're not okay
oh my god and you're feminist they're
gonna get you i don't think i mean i
kind of feel like if it hasn't happened
by now
you yeah maybe they're cool maybe
they're cool i i would like to meet them
i'm curious i
now that i can like set boundaries very
well i think that'd be a crazy podcast
crazy podcast
okay if you're related to me please
reach out to benton and you can come on
the podcast
so i do know that two exist um
but my big fear was that the good news
is that you smell pheromones differently
if you're related like
incest is not rewarded uh uh
biologically dr hubermann talked about
that when he was on the podcast
so if a guy smells bad to you like if
you ever like hooked up
close your ears husband have you ever um
like if you ever like hooked up with a
guy or girl that just like doesn't smell
good like their bo doesn't smell
okay that means you're related in some
way that is nature's way
of making sure you're repelled by your
um
brothers and sisters or anyone you're
related to so that you don't commit it i
always think my brother's really stinky
yeah he's when he gets close to me i'm
like bro you're just you're actually my
brother oh
like i would go into his room when i was
kidding it's like yeah like it's like
makes me sick
i worry for him and his future wife i'm
like no but it's
good to her if they're not related
because you know because you're a guy
you saw yeah yeah
yeah yeah you smell your yeah that
smells amazing his breath
can be slamming but yeah but other than
that yeah
we were together before he knocked you
up um
oh wait no no no i want to know your
version and her version
2016 is when we started today one time
oh yeah and i we started dating and i
had to go on tour like four days after
but i knew he was the one so how did you
like
because um red flags
i checked red flags and there was zero i
mean i mean i'm
literally dressed as a sparkly red flag
yeah yeah yeah i'm a big red flag i'm a
list you got it
red flags let the girls know uh well
mine
the reason why i couldn't find anyone
well no when i got famous and extra
pretty
um because i figured this shit out i was
like
oh not gonna do dark eyeliner just that
and no eyebrows
um i became so pretty and uh i guess
like no one would hook up with me dude
my first few years of being famous
and like successful no no no no nobody
would touch me no and i was like bro is
it too powerful i would tell my brother
cause he would bring all his friends
over and i was like
i was like it's new year's eve someone
gave me a kiss everyone's like we would
never do that to your brother and i was
like
and my brother's like kiss her it's fine
i don't care
but they were like sit and i was like am
i scary i was like i know i have a
presence
i get it am i scary but also do i come
off come off as like don't approach me
like i'm not into you already and ryan's
like your pointy ass boobs they're so
sharp they were just watch out
they're dangerous my brother's like no
dude you're just like super confident or
something like he's like you're just
really cool
and that's scary to guys that's right
and i was like okay
so not all guys not all guys daryl was
the first guy that wasn't scared of me
and like kissed me first and like
usually i'm like hold still
like i'm coming in but he did everything
and i was like who are you
mr brave yeah and i needed someone who
could deal with my schedule
like i'm leaving forever i always said i
need my trust fund baby so that i can
just carry him around
and be like take care of me daryl is an
actor
who like at the time didn't have a job
so it was great because i was like are
you doing anything he's like no i'm not
working right now and i was like awesome
on tour great yeah and then serve our
first days of
our first month of dating was like
here's how i poop here's how i sleep
here's how i eat
like here's how i shower everything so
it was no awkwardness
no awkwardness i mean i was scared to
poop in front of him forever
i was like you turn on something really
loud and stay the fuck away from me wait
so
why in front of him how big is your
bathroom
why in front poop in front of you you
poop in front of him nowadays i do now
it's an event now i'm like come hang out
with me
um how long does it take you to poop i
hold out for
the last second um so that it's like a
quick thing
i so he has to come in just to like just
like why did i run all the way in here
boys
i don't know oh i'm getting sweaty
you it's always when i put up with the
birth is he gonna be in the room hell
yeah
cause you know poop comes out he knows
you're right but that's what i prepared
him for that day
oh he knows he's seen it nothing will be
because
that usually is the biggest plot trust
of having the baby
people are scared i'm like i know
someone who was right he's gonna wipe
that
up for me rolling on it rolling on it
was like oop
and then the camera jumps away because
he didn't know doo doo comes out when
the baby comes yeah
no he's fully prepared he's so excited
he's so ready
um i train him to get ready for that
stuff trainer
i'm a trainer total sense but yeah you
can
i think that's an awesome part of but
did you like fall off a
jungle gym or something as a kid why are
you so like resiliently strong
i was the monkey bar queen yeah like
something right like what was that i
mean
i might do maguire hillary what's her
name duff stuff
uh she yes i saw this and she was a
gymnast
you know what i mean i played football i
played baseball
not only did i play football i played
football and was the center
which is like i had the ball and i'm
pushing it up massachusetts is a fucking
place the worst part about this place
they're like tom brady
bro the coat yes the coach was my dad's
good friend
we grew up with him he had me be center
and my
older brother get the ball
like quarterback so he's in my crotch
every day at practice and i'm just
like i'm hitting him the ball so you've
already had your birthing class
with my older brother it's so messed up
i was like why did y'all let this happen
to me
with all the boys all the boys i was the
only girl i played baseball with all the
boys i was the only girl
that's what needs to happen i think boys
need to stop playing football and girls
need to start playing football or just
let them in
it was like a whole scene too they were
like oh you're so brave
and i was like what i just want to play
with what's up me when i don't wear
makeup on camera
people say that to me like paparazzi
picks with me out in public they're like
brave megan didn't wear makeup and i had
a whole cake on
that i put i'm like what does that
fucking say okay
i was like i did all my makeup that day
and to mince cake
i mean just fully so yeah i was a tough
girl
and all my friends were the cheerleaders
you were not a cheerleader
i did it for one year but only because i
made the track
i produced the track for them put all
our favorite songs in together mixed it
and then was like i produce this beat
while i try to be a cheerleader it's
like you're a dancer it's like you're a
hoe dancer for a minute
what was your favorite movie growing up
woof
that hit me with a heavy one yeller
um just friends by
yeah from justin to kelly the justin to
kelly's story
i mean i was there um no
just friends ryan reynolds do you not
know that fucking movie
i don't think so uh oh my cancelled
i might be how about this ryan fucking
wrestlers would you wear a fat suit
oh with gwen the paltrow that shallow
howl
wait hold on you would love this movie
no i wouldn't yes you would i probably
don't like that you hate it i already no
i don't ryan reynolds let me tell you
something about ryan reynolds not only
is i
i think he's so famous and successful i
still think he's underrated by the way
yeah how funny i think he is yes but
when i went to school in pennsylvania in
philadelphia
i interviewed him well for my i'm
literally just i had blacked all this
out because my college was uh it was an
upsetting time it was a dark time
triggered i
interviewed him for the campus news
station when he was doing
a show called two guys and a girl in a
pizza place
and then he did a national lampoon movie
called van wilder yeah
and i interviewed him in his hotel room
in the woods carl and i was like 18
years old and i was like
he was like extra good looking then too
dude he's oh yeah
so fine and by the way by the way
i don't even know if i'm physically
attracted to him i think the reason i'm
so attracted to him is because
he was married to atlanta's morrison oh
that was like
that's forget that that's i know that's
why now he's got blake
who's i mean i'm like oh my god
joe for a minute right oh yeah stay
married i think my mom tells me all this
the guy's killing it she knows all the
hollywood drama kelly kelly
hey hot news on twitter
zola listen there are a million choices
you know that zola is the daughter's
name on grey's anatomy
i did and i would beat you in a trivial
quiz at a bar any about
any day zola what are the other two kids
names
[Music]
um oh we're moving on quickly i see wait
listen
on grey's anatomy the other two kids
yeah her kids grades
tina and benny one is close actually
what the benny one what where what are
they
bailey zola and like
i forgot the other one because it's
exactly it's a child's deal so it has no
storyline
listen there are about a million choices
to make when you're planning a wedding
as we all know
planning a wedding is a nightmare so
many of my
fall friends love love of their lives
soulmate
found him got him got her
oh my god so happy stuff got them they
they them then them her she him them
them
and then they start planning the wedding
hate each other i truly think that the
act of planning a wedding can ruin your
relationship
well lucky for you zola has helped over
1 million couples get married and have
everything you need planned zola is like
a wedding planner like a digital
wedding yes it makes wedding planning
easier and less stressful with wedding
websites registries invites
you talk away handy guest list managers
all in one place
this is how i normally talk talking like
you're reading an ad no i'm not
i am just talking how i read like make
it like a conversation
they don't we've been told not to do
that multiple times
i just i truly believe that like
this wedding planners are a racket i
just want to be a wedding planner
you did i used to carry out a wedding
planning book around high school
you did like a psychopath whose wedding
was i planning
all those teen pregnancies i was like
here i am here's my card
because it's it's a it's a good in
theory
it's a fun idea but it's a nightmare you
can't play on your own wedding
and wedding planners overcharge you they
scam you
like i know how much flowers cost i make
i make television shows i make movies
sorry i'm bragging now
but i and then all of a sudden when i
was planning a wedding
they're like six thousand dollars so no
well they were two thousand dollars when
i was making a movie why are they six
thousand now
wedding's more important than your movie
wow
all of it you create your own website
custom url
password protection website features you
have
you have to have a wedding website when
you get married you know so everyone
knows where to go and so they stopped
what's the hashtag put it on the website
otherwise they're gonna call you and
text you and be like where do i park and
where do i go and where's the hotel and
what am i supposed to do and it's gonna
make your life a nightmare
and you're gonna start hating your
friends also we know weddings are about
gifts and zola's registry is easy to use
and flexible so guests can give you
gifts you
actually want add a mix of gifts
experiences and honeymoon funds you can
do all of it they can give you
everything they own
find your perfect wedding paper
zola handled design in logistics
this is dude you're we're laughing
because
but when you get married it's so fucking
important
you you want a clown we always clown
bridez-ella's and brosella franzella's
when they're getting married
because we're like oh who gives a shit
about the paper it's so important
it means everything so your wedding day
gorgeous affordable cards every wedding
style all designed to match
zola's free wedding website zola will
help you collect addresses track online
rsvp's what doesn't zola do jesus christ
i want to
address your envelopes for free i want
to marry zola
right yeah zola helped plan my wedding
to zola well we'll see go to zola.com
whitney today and use promo code save 50
to get 50
off your save the dates you can also get
a free personalized paper sample before
you purchase that's 50
off save the dates at zola.com whitney
promo code save 50.
okay benton
[Music]
the only thing that is more competent at
keeping me alive
than benton ray hickerson is every
doctor in los angeles no
his daily harvest i love my daily
harvest i think
i am i allowed to say that i'd be dead
without this company
i seriously think i would have died of
melanoma without sponsorships you
wouldn't we wouldn't have a lot okay
food
water beverages literally i am such
a trash person i am these are my
favorite ones
my favorite they're the bites benton
loves daily harvest so much he's
freaking out
oh my god i really can't get it open
look have you had these yet what are
they you get your own these are
the they're the oh my god i love these
these are this is my favorite the bites
they make are my favorite
no no it's not a treat okay these are
little um espresso bean
and tahini sesame it's like eating a
starbucks coffee
it's so good it's like eating a coffee
daily harvest is like
it's just this company that
sends you food that gives you no choice
but to
be healthy it delivers yeah they deliver
delicious
fresh organic food organic fruits
vegetables right to your door
like combinations you'd never think of
yeah they take very few minutes to
prepare this took no time to prepare i
just ate it oh my god
doesn't it taste like you're eating a
coffee i don't think i can curve
but daily harvest there's an option no
added sugar
they work directly with farms to freeze
now i'm eating
yeah but they also make you eat on the
podcast people hate it
oh you've never done it they don't like
it before so are you just retelling
yourself
the daily harvest there's an option for
listen this is the best thing that
they've heard in my opinion is that it's
not just like you know some meal plans
you can only order like dinner or lunch
yeah they there's
snacks there's lunch there's dinner
there's breakfast there's i can eat all
day i can have a crisp flatbread
whenever i want if you go to this is
what i do with daily harvest when i go
to someone's house and i
don't want to eat their food i just
bring one of these little things and i
just eat it
i don't care if they think it's rude and
they usually are like where'd you get
that
what's tell me about it do you have a
promo code well i told you my favorite
one is the bites the espresso
and espresso espresso
expressive intake
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to enjoy it helping
reduce
food waste daily heart is committed to
minimizing their environmental impact
and they're in the process of
transitioning to a hundred percent
recyclable
plant-based and renewable fiber
packaging like if you're a mom dude or
like just a
whatever you're mothering your own inner
child it's just like such a no-brainer
oh they're so easy i like don't go to
the grocery store
it's all just in here look at this
tomato
sweet potato wild rice avocado red bell
pepper nutritional yeast
uh and great northern bean like i would
never eat i never
i never even heard of a great northern
bean i thought that was me
the great southern bean daily harvest
makes it easy to eat clean
undeniably delicious food no matter what
your day brings keep it simple with
daily harvest
go to dailyharvest.com and enter promo
code good for you
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code good for you for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com
and so while this is wild this is
blowing my mind so so i'm just trying
i'm just trying to figure out how we
your psyche form okay okay okay
oh i mean my parents let us watch like
dark stuff when we were really young
like
um because your mind is wildly fast
thank you
i feel so dumb sometimes um
we grew up watching like uh like austin
powers like really young
like in the theater so they shouldn't
have let us by the way demi moore
produce
has producing credit makes money on back
end on the no way
wow yep all of them love women owning
shit
women ownership um what else did i
uh my family and i always loved
like family guy as a family i don't know
we're just like dark humor
loved that we loved um comedians you
don't have an
ego oh thank you you know what i mean i
guess
like you don't because i also like at
the same time as i can be really
confident
you know i'm a woman who like
finds the imperfections and like
despises yourself at some times you know
so i still got that going for me do you
have good skin always no
you think i have good skin yeah yes
i said it allison christian my makeup
artist um
i started uh uh in my 20s i started
getting i would like
in your twenties no no in the beginning
of my twenties i got it like in high
school i get like one
or one big one or one the cystic
yeah it was um no but in like 22 23
started getting cheap pimples and i was
like you don't belong there
no we're right i'm ross
i'm on tv and they're like oh it's
because all the makeup darling and i'm
like
i don't know this is new and now i'm
learning like when you grow up
your face changes every seven years and
i have new skin
literally figured out right now it's
like my beard your female comic you
actually get a new face everything you
get
i know i was like okay we can work with
this there's doctors everywhere
but my pimple's right down here well
that's hormonal and the chin is
hormonal that's what everyone's saying i
think so since you've been pregnant is
it
as you're changing yeah i in the
beginning i was like
okay on your neck daryl get it oh yeah
yeah yeah but i'm lucky that it's not
like full back knee or which i've heard
of or
chest yesterday yes um
so yeah i work on my skin so thank you
for that and you're and
when did you know you knew how to you do
have excellent genes which is why i want
to know where
they're from thank you so much um and
also
how do you know you can and i want to
talk about how i'm fascinated
by how people can sing and why they can
sing oh strictly
because i listen to people and copy them
yes but
you are born with a certain kind of
musculature i
have a really great ear i can say that
i hear too much shit yes but i can hear
uh too much shit and i don't have the
physical ability to
execute the impression so like when
you're singing and it's off you don't go
huh
i have made myself deaf with my own
voice
so i can't hear i don't think really
anything okay then
yeah but see you told me i'm tone deaf
see but can you hear that
she's i mean she told me that and i can
you personally hear it with your ear
are you like yeah it's not best it's not
the best yeah it's a struggle i mean i
know i sound like fran drescher so i'm
not
mad okay i know how i sound i know i'm
nasal but apparently
none of us really know how we sound
because of right because where they're
positioned
yeah but like how what's the first time
you know you can sing i'm just curious
because i was like running around every
time i was just running around my house
again i was like singing christmas
carols and all these yeah
pop stars so it is a gift my dad can
some people sing and some can
my dad's a big showman guy so he hosted
the
so creepy when people just like look at
you while they're typing in the
psychopath
um my dad hosted a show on nantucket
called march of dimes where they raised
money for babies i know it and so he was
like
for the adrenaline hey everyone he'd
sing a song and he'd
play piano he was the music guy and um
so i i was on that show with him singing
tunes and i was in church with him
singing tunes
some of it's genetic it wasn't good till
i was 16 when i went away to a musical
camp
and my roommate's saying way better than
me and i literally copied her
and i went home and they're like wow you
got so much better and i was like
yup and i would study like jojo
singing on her album when she was
thrilled
closed captioning not
it with a available of her so i made
sure when i recorded my music
and then i started like i was like dad i
need to record my voice i need to hear
it on a cd
so he got me like my christmas gifts
would be like here's garageband
or here's a program that you can learn i
don't know how to use it but you figure
it out and then i just did
so i was like producing and writing my
own because your dad's like 80 at this
point
he's 100 he's like 72 now but in my head
he's 98
like he's like your mom's he still runs
around
like cleaning my whole house and fixing
things yeah that massachusetts genetics
i mean they don't they're just
he worked like seven times a week my
whole life yeah he won't give up
it's found that roughly 20 of people
can't sing accurately because they don't
have good control of their vocal muscles
and five percent of lousy singers lack
the ability to hear differences in pitch
or discriminate between two different
sounds to be sure some aspects of
singing are influenced by genetics
because it's about how fast your
vocal cords move right it's like a
muscle
it's a muscle that's what they say it's
like a kegel yeah so i
like i squeezed mine too much one time
and i got a pimple on them
did you have the nodes on your oh so
singers and so i wasn't
born to tour i wasn't born with cords
that could handle anything
so uh vocal cords what do you do to take
care of your vocal cords you shut the
fuck up
so we're giving you a node right now no
yeah like a lot of times when i do it
seven hours when i do
i would always need surgery after i
would do all this you had surgery on
your vocal cords
twice a year after i won the grammy on
the day of the next grammys i had vocal
surgery
it was weird they go out with a little
thingy i'm a gagger well you're asleep
you want to be there oh it's a real
you're under like it's a real surgery
it's crazy
and you're just silent for like five
months and like imagine what your brain
would do
with five months of no talking i went
absolutely you're a handmaid i went yeah
batshit crazy
and i i had like what do you do you go
full panic disorder that's right i fell
in love with you because
yeah well he fell in love with me in
that time and now they're like you're so
happy why are you shaking with me he
loves me so much because we've never met
yeah we've never seen he's never seen my
personality
that's what yeah i was so cool i forgot
to let that out he just watches me shit
it was hard because i was like i'm so in
love with you and the saddest part is i
can't even tell you i love you
like rom-com oh tears cheers i'd be
crying if i didn't i had all my tears
this morning i have like four movies i
gotta do
yeah but um he was so good to me took
care of me
starring lizzy yeah but it's
it's it's spooky and a lot of artists go
through it and they don't talk about it
because they can't yeah because they're
not allowed to literally can't but that
was the hard part is like
um besides quarantine like every other
cycle i would go
fly to new york sing on fallon fly over
here
sing an hour-long show do a podcast for
four hours go do this
and my voice i was like i'm out like i
can't do it
i can't physically do it and does
doesn't hurt yeah you get a sore throat
i coughed up blood once it's kind of hot
yeah but yeah i don't it's tough so
so you because you're like an athlete i
mean it's you're really an athlete
yeah you have to yeah i was like my body
is like you're no no
we stay home so you have to take so you
have to schedule your life and your
albums around
the five months of vocal down time
basically right oh writing for that
writing song when you know like i have
to do surgery
everything's done and that's the hard
part i was getting an award
so this pandemic like you were ready
singers were for the pandemic i was like
oh yeah like five months yeah we had one
day where i did
all the performances in one day and i
was like that's it they're all locked in
they're done and now i can just go chit
chat whatever i want and i don't have to
worry about it go breed
yeah i'ma go pre-humans so this is our
time
so when you are the five months where
your
vocal cords are healing or you're not
allowed to talk at all
which is just blowing my mind um are you
because i'm trying to i think that's
kind of fascinating like creatively like
what happens to your brain
the frustration the emotions that come
up not being able to literally be heard
literally not being able to communicate
with people or connect with people
emotionally
does that bleed out that was my great
um education of what anxiety does to
your body
because i would always hear all this all
my fans say like oh i
would throw up or i'd have diarrhea or
i'd be sick and like
i physically couldn't leave my house and
i was like i've never been that sad
and i related it to being sad i was like
i've never had anxiety that sad where i
can't get out of bed
and then this took over my body to where
i had diarrhea
uncontrollably and i was burning like my
back would be on fire and i'd be like
what the heck
i have the flu and i had no idea what's
happening and i was happy i was fine
but my body was like crumbling from
being still for so long and it was
almost like my body realized
the four years of fame that just hit me
all at once
and so my body was sitting there like
something wrong
and i went to these doctors and now i'm
like the advice girl when anyone's going
through it i text i'm like yo i got the
doctor i got everything you need what do
you need because
it's lonely well because i want to talk
about like
the great musicians uh in history of
what you are going you will be one of
those
do you know what i um
it pains me to say it i'm not happy
about it jealous
um but which we will be and you look at
the whitney houstons you look at the
michael jacksons you look at and i'm i i
just
always fascinated by like what what
causes their demise what causes that
tragic ending the shakespearean
the biblical fall bad families bad
families but bad families sometimes make
hard workers and really talented people
and sensitive people and
they're great creatives yeah bad
families for sure
but i feel like it always ends bad
you're going to break the cycle yeah
right because you've got a wonderful
family
for now um
until they get the till they go crazy
off this christmas album fame
all that money is they're gonna get
until they get drunk in backgrounds yes
no but um
but i'm always fascinated like what is
it chicken is it egg were they always
uh hypersensitive overwhelmed by life
not uh strong enough to handle
is it all the fame because that amount
of energy coming at you is a trauma it's
an emotional trauma it's isolating it's
alienating but i've never thought about
or the trauma you're going through all
the
sexual predators and assholes and
psychopaths in the business that are
fucking with you and gaslighting yeah
stealing from you and all that
and then you're losing friends because
they get jealous and i mean there's all
of them it's very traumatic being famous
yeah
i've never thought about the physical
part
and it's weird that we're not talking
about vocal cords like why don't you
talk about that one
that one's like oh i have i've worked
too hard and now i have to stop and
disappoint all of you
is that why famous singers take like
pain killers and stuff do you think any
of it has to do with those surgeries or
their voices no that's like a big
back surgery or something or titties or
oh i don't know i
like this one you don't i don't even you
don't really need i know but i'm
but if you're if if cause i know like a
lot of professional athletes like nfl
players like they're still hooked on all
these like
yeah those are like real because they
just give them painkillers before they
go out and play
so that they can play they tried to give
me a lot of pills for stuff like that
for my anxiety they were like
here taking some you know nexium the
nexium called no they
they are like tape take um if you get
spooked because i was
i had to perform an ellen a month after
my surgery yeah and i was like guys i'm
not gonna make it like how am i gonna do
this you're just scared because you know
that i was like what if i environment
i was like what if i pass out or have a
full panic attack during the performance
and
she's like you take it once that's it um
so
and it's not a beta blocker scary no
yeah but beta blockers are actually okay
they yeah
they're fine i do those i do i did those
for a long time those are dope yep um
so yeah then i slowly stopped doing that
and i slowly now got
i was taking like the smallest dose of
ativan every single night
but with the pregnancy like they're like
get off and i did it and i was like i
don't know if i can get off and i was
like
i did it i feel like a hero like i'm a
champion yeah
placebo thing anyway sugar water like
there's nothing in there
for me like when i had ativan for
anxiety it was like just having it in my
purse
yeah is what made me just keep it close
like i have it
yeah i don't really have to take it i
just need to know that i can my doctor
was like
literally people are on a hundred times
more than i know this is like a silly
dose
this is 0.5 and i was like okay so that
helped me
so are you prepared because um having a
baby is going to change
you love it but your talent banking on
that too that'd be nice so you're gonna
you're gonna just like exponentially
like blossom because now you're gonna
have
um an understanding of the universe in
the world and purpose
that you've never had so is that gonna
be is that exactly
good news or bad news that's that makes
me so happy because i
my whole life i like well recently too
when i met daryl there's some weird
thing of like that's how you know he's
the one
where when i would walk by diapers with
him i'd cry
i'd literally tear up and be like you
should be buying me that's like i
want a kid and i asked my guy i have to
shit right now because i hold
out last i second like asked my
therapist i'm like am i
fucked up that i cry when i see diapers
she's like no you're just already
mothering your kids and it's very sweet
and i was like just sad the fact that
you go buy your own stuff alone and
don't have an assistant do it for you
i never had a system buy some for me but
yeah um
why are you in therapy i wasn't there
because it was the panic disorder time
she cured me i was great wow i literally
was like don't need you thank you
yeah awesome but it was had to do with
the vocal cords yeah
it was all that stuff um and then
so i've always wanted a kid and i'm so
excited i want like a hundred
what uh can we pick the name you want to
pick the name
or are we gonna be um secretive about it
like you don't want to tell anyone the
name i have a name and we're like let's
not tell anyone can i try to guess it
you could try you'll never go boy it's
gonna be a boy
for now yeah no no for now for now it's
a boy yeah sorry but i made sure the
name was good for both for now
i made sure the name could switch in
case he was like not today
okay where is he from where's um uh out
here grew up in l.a what
he's a spy kid bro you know spy kids you
probably don't
scott's got spy kids
remember this franchise that was like
lots of money yeah
frankie muniz no
i'm just my name's not frankie okay he's
writing venus but he's not
famous oh my god he had a mouse not the
whole time he was hiding his famous face
jenny
kids hold on hold on hold on dude it's
okay
you just were too cool to watch it you
were just for two sweet valley high
it's like yeah i didn't have a childhood
movie one two one what year did this
come out
2001. yeah i was cute i was in
uh deep in the throes of uh
being unconscious i was in college
college
you said i was in college in philly at
the time spy kids would have come out it
would have been very weird if i saw that
it's weird if you watched it
as a pedophile yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
um that's dope but kids still watch it
today because it's always in the new
family movies
yeah spy kids that's a big deal is it
like a disney thing yes yes
yes okay it's like this is very cute oh
there's a baby in the poster this is
wild little kids that run around and
solve crimes
who's your mom in carl i love carla
gugino
she's dope they're done they're
beautiful she's on hunting hill house
yes she is yeah yeah yeah so she they
were spies in the movie
and the kids were like they found out
our parents aren't they're not
cool they're not spies and they're like
they're surprised and they become spicy
but that movie wouldn't work anymore
because you could just google stuff
yes just bring cameras and google earth
they're like
we're all spies right we're all spies
yeah you have an alexa yeah
i don't i'm like the last person yes i
do
alexa play my song yeah i'm like just
tell your alexa to play megan trainer
okay so your um baby your baby
he grew up he grew up in orange county
and was famous
torrance he grew up in shit i'm sorry oh
that's interesting you have a good
access animal hospital in toronto and he
was like a jiu jitsu
your alias was dirt diggler and what is
that is that from fight club
i think i know i don't know you're just
like me i know nothing no i know
a lot no you don't know it i think
you know nothing but it makes you cute
i know a lot about like science
oh that's good that's better it's now
outdated that's more important
yeah what is that wait who's dirk
diggler wait don't tell me that the um
the
the dude was he the guy
man hold on dirk diggler i know what
this is
uh dirk diggler chippendale uh channing
tatum
nope uh oh magic mike
matthew mcconaughey you want me on your
in your game night on your picture mark
mark wahlberg
i'm so sorry in my day mark wahlberg was
a rapper
he was marky mark in the funky bunch and
he was a calvin klein model and i
refused to see him any differently
that's who i guess his wife actually
uh is um picked out the perfume that i
wear
the brazilian horror uh stripper wow
brazilian nut what's it called brazilian
bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
her and i bum like i want to fuck you
and she's like let me tell you i don't
know
what's the perfume how much is it is it
expensive it's eight dollars and it
smells like strippers
yes yeah it's so good makes me fall in
love people are like wow why do you
smell so good i'm like yeah
yeah it's like a bodies yeah there's a
butt cream
so how did you decide on your baby name
um we talked about it
but how did it did you like there's no
like there's a dead relative always take
that but
none of that was the second runner-up
name
well that's i have the my name for my
second child fuck
so you want to keep that what was the
set what were the ones that almost made
it
okay uh baby names names are so
important i liked
i liked one name that he really didn't
like because i thought it was different
but i like regular names like i don't
want aqua or i don't want like some
fancy
color or something i don't know i don't
want i wanted just like a regular
regular name yeah
so and i saw this is so lame there was
like a list of names that i had to say
i'd do a little video for for fans of
like hey you
i saw kyler and i thought that was cute
and i and i wanted to be a name that i
don't know a person that's named yeah
yeah because you have an association
yeah she bullied me
she was prom queen yeah ever um i didn't
know what kyler and i was like that's
cool
uh he hated that name yeah it's okay my
kids are fine
yeah so the other one and it's it's
basically
who do you what name do you like that
you don't know a human being like that
interesting so you'll never get i like
um like
harold i like old old guys hairy names
yeah i like old guy names
that's the new jelly i like billy i
would do rocky i would do
i'm very into rocky but didn't someone
have a i love stormy but kylie did it
yes yeah daniel's not great stormy
daniels
is that to be my baby's google search
yeah you know
do you have a middle name what's your
middle name so lame
the middle name of my baby yeah um this
one's named after people
that we like and then was it planned to
your baby yes
yeah oh my gosh heavily i was pissed
heavily
i was peeing on sticks every day to make
sure i was ovulating i'm like and i had
apps
i even got a plug that's a whole nother
thing you don't want to know
i do i actually do i took vitamins
i want what i did was i looked on
youtube every single day how did you get
pregnant
and all these people were like okay
here's here's like the trick i did that
definitely
worked which was white fucking none of
them worked yeah yeah but
you could have having sex you could have
sex too much and it doesn't work which
is why
we did that every single day i'm not
pregnant
i said every single day three times a
day let's rock and then it didn't work
wait wait wait wait
wait i didn't achieve that it was like
twice a day
he was tired i don't know i was like i
okay get a microphone
oh wait that yes three times a day no i
think your body hurts
shut down and goes like and i'm just
like legs up
waiting 20 minutes like please work you
know but
that didn't work so and then i heard
someone on youtube
say is your doctor uh dr drew i didn't
yes that's why
i didn't go to a doctor before to check
if i was good yeah just like let's go i
got this
yeah and then i went online and they
said if you do it too much you your
sperm gets weaker
so maybe that's why oh shit that's why
you don't deal with the same person
every time
exactly see we got it then we we held
out
and we i made him wait and we only did
it on that day
that i might pee thing that gave me a
smiley face and said you're ovulating
uh-huh and we only did it that day one
time then never
did it ever again no we never did it
give a video do you have a photo
um we i remember it i did uh
i think about uh getting sperm recently
fun to get pregnant myself i know
yeah um trust
it's nice people i love you pregnant i'm
like i gotta get pregnant so we could be
pregnant yes
literally i'm alone as hell right now
like such of like fomo well hillary you
have
we're cutting it out we're cutting it
out oh my god i was so alone until then
but yeah
is she gonna she'll now okay i know
oh my god my heart wait we can't do that
you're lucky that i knew bro you're fine
you're fine
you guys that's the biggest secret i
have right now oh
my god i was like does she know oh my
god okay
we're fine we're in charge your eyes to
me you're in charge i know
you're i saw you give up on live you're
like well i'm done
i literally was just like this is why we
can't do this live yeah
did it work like i don't know
like holy shit i just made this friend
i was like me too bro fucking don't
really see me not to talk about on the
fucking podcast
that's why we've been friends now
because my baby is my only excuse i'm
like let me in
hey help me out she's like i'll be your
mom my friend i'm like thank you
okay oh my god okay i'm so alone in this
pregnancy i have nobody
no i want to get pregnant just because
like i have fomo and i want to get
pregnant with somebody else i want to
like fit in oh all i have on my youtube
gals that don't know i
study them all day this is what i
learned which is that
uh it you're more likely to get pregnant
if you have an
orgasm sure
oh i got pregnant never had one
no i my mom's gonna
kill me i am a champion at that like
better than all my friends are
um i've tested this theory you know i
i'm i'm like yeah i'm one of the ones
that figured it out when i was like
really young uh-huh
how young uncomfortably young
nobody knows this side uh i found out
way too early king floyd's off i'm
comfortably young and i would ask my
parents and they totally avoided me i
was on a bike ride once yeah no shit
what does this mean your dad might want
to go to jail
and i was like i had questions and you
never gave me a talk
or anything so i didn't know it's
inappropriate or what's going on yeah so
i'm champion at that
so that happens every time for me it's
great um
yeah yeah yeah wow well no i mean
there's like
it's a two-way street it's not just
inside what do you mean inside
do you mean like just what do you mean
there's friends involved there's like
it takes a team everyone's gotta be all
my buttons have to be proud how many
people are you fucking at one time
he's mr octagon he's amazing he's a
whole castle he's given him he does
everything for me um and he's just he's
a boy he's he's a twister
yes it's a game of twister for me and he
achieves that every time
i also taught him i trained him in the
beginning i said i can get to fireworks
if you help me out
and he got it day one and i was like we
should get married
i was like this should be our thing
that's how you know you can be with them
forever too it's like damn
dark we're set there i love you as a
person i could be stuck in a room with
you for 18 hours and love generation of
women are having orgasms
i mean i feel very alone none of my
friends can do it like interesting
you know i was your star old soul that
nantucket ghost
your vagina's haunted
earnest if we said it once we've said it
on other podcasts earn it student loans
have you heard about them
student loans ruining the lives of
everyone just a nightmare
what an asshole what an asshole
well take advantage of you when you're
at your most
vulnerable they bully you they send you
hate mail when you're
at your most hopeful you think
everything's going to work out in life
i'm going to
pay for college they're going to loan me
money how nice of them
then they're going to call you days and
weekends for it back gosh what
but earnest is the easiest way to
refinance your student loans saving you
time and money
liars thieves and worms and as sheri
would say gypsies tramps and thieves
but we can't say gypsies anymore and i
forgot
we can in this ad checking out checking
your new rate
is fast and easy to start complete a few
questions online it only takes two
minutes and you'll get a personalized
rate estimate rushing all without
affecting your credit score
i'm gonna haunt the people if you
qualify earnest offers
customizable loan terms and no fees
you can even combine private and federal
loans imagine having one single monthly
payment
that would be awesome because when i was
paying off my student loans i had to pay
three
separate payments ugh nightmare it's
what a hassle it's also it's like the re
the everything you learned in college
like you
i you didn't teach me how to pay these
loans
i don't think you just said what a
hassle
can you believe they're out here doing
this to us what a
tom foolery listen this is how you know
earnest is a good service that really
works because
the internet loves earnest their
customer service is rated a
9.4 out of 10 on trustpilot so i mean
the internet they don't lie no
people on the internet don't need to be
nice yeah they don't go out of their way
to be nice that's for sure
start saving today our listeners get a
100 cash bonus when you refinance a
student loan at earnest.com
whitney that's a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
at earnest.com
whitney go to earnest.com whitney today
terms and conditions apply
what did you just say benton so i have
the white sheets you have the white
sheets
and the next one order i bought i bought
the off-white that i kind of cream
colored one
i've never had a sheet i like to wear my
life it never looks dirty it always
looks clean
it washes out perfectly and they are by
far the softest she's ever had
here's what benton does with our
sponsors because we are very picky about
the sponsors we take we only do the ones
that we
actually use and pay for and buy
brook linen uh sheets is no exception
before we start doing the ad benton will
organically talk about how much he loves
the product
and then when we start rolling he'll go
into most of these products i've used
way before i knew you but then during
the ad he'll go into his like vanna
white voice and be like if you haven't
done something in brooklyn no no no and
then it doesn't sound like you really
use it just a quick question for the
producers who's getting notes me or
whitney
brooklyn we love
you uh nothing is uh the only safe space
anymore
we have is our bed let's be honest but
they got you covered from your bed to
your bathroom bathroom oh the towels
the towels are wise i'm a towel
snob most of the towels you buy don't
even dry you they just move the water
around
on you most of the towels just scratch
me i'm just
i just cut up and still wet i'm just
bleeding i'm
bleeding into my own river this is
honestly
if you're my friend and you're listening
please only get me this
brook linen for christmas this is all i
want all i want is towels
and sheets from brooklyn and it is the
kindest thing you can
do for me oh that would be a great gift
getting someone cheating
it sounds stupid but it'll be amazing
it's an amazing that's what people
actually
need yep they have exceptional gifts
uh there's always people on your list
that are like tough to buy for
and you know this you could kind of like
can't go wrong
um towels candles
silk eye masks scrunchies robes
oh and everything is so aesthetically
pleasing
or my favorite gift a gift card oh
that's a really good idea i'll make my
own i love it i love it
i can do a lot with my brain and someone
else's money no but i need to touch
something
i'd rather you give me it and i'll
return it well we're in a pandemic so
you give me a gift card and i'll make
the right choice the first time
uh cozy up i'm impressed all my beds are
covered in brooklyn and
uh i actually have to move to a new
house because my sinus infections
all my bed is covered in brooklyn too
taking all my brooklyn and sheets with
me
remember they were like you can use our
sheets i was like no no thanks i'll
bring my own they're like you can use
our sheets and you were like i have my
own
yeah that literally happened today i was
like i will be bringing mine i'll bring
i'll be bringing towels
robes candles i got it i'm not going to
sleep on your like
trash sheets brooklyn's sponsoring this
rental
i think you said brooklyn on my bed it's
like me too on my bed
um cozy up to brooklyn's biggest sell of
the year happening right now
brooklyn is so confident in their
product that all their sheets
comforters loungewear and towels come
with 365
day warranty get huge savings and free
shippings during brooklyn's biggest sale
of the year
only at brooklyn.com that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and use promo code whitney to let them
know our show sent you
that's brooklyn.com promo code whitney
and if you can't wait for the sale or if
you're just hearing this and it's
post black friday cyber monday you can
still use the promo code whitney
brooklyn.com for 10 off and free
shipping in the u.s
anytime yes my mom's gonna
die okay sorry girlie bye now
no sorry it's like great one's a knots
on grandma um yeah
so um why are we talking about this
making babies i'm obsessed with
i was with you i knew we'd be best
friends um i'm completely obsessed with
you
that happened you even asked me the
friend question what huh
are we friends are we bishop i watch you
are we friends yeah we weren't in the
beginning yeah know
i walked in your house like a stranger
well you know it was so wild she
i do my podcast in my house everybody
knows this it's very weird
you came in and fucking bent and i have
been fighting all morning because your
christmas album they sent it to me ahead
of time but it's on a website for
some like it's so hard to play so every
time i'm playing it and that's why i
brought it because i was like that's
gonna suck and every time yeah and i
don't even know what this is what is
this
it's the minidisc what is that oh
they're the new news yeah it's just even
plastic
where do i play this on a blu-ray uh i
know where can people pop this
i don't know only an old car single yeah
so
we used to get singles dude but this is
cute you know the oldest do you remember
singles like this i used to go to tower
record
tobias i'm from dc dave girl will know
what i'm talking about you're watching
uh the wiz and you'd get like a single
you'd be like i would like the new
silver chair single that's when people
made money from this
now i gotta do bullshit so what's up
with this so you're so what's how is the
model of music making changing i know
what's happening in comedy
i make i don't make my money from like
touring and
no why not because i'm not in arenas i'm
not justin bieber
i'm not doing stadiums you know i'm
doing
i was just my last tour that was just me
or headlining
oh i'm gonna burp was like just touching
arenas i was almost there i was like
in big baby rooms that was so close um
and then to get canceled then i had my
uh
surgery and had to stop sucks
i know but yeah no i always like and
they would tell me on my last tour like
you're gonna
break even and i'm like okay this is
hard
yeah it's a lot of work so what you're
doing when you go tour with yeah
even is just promoting the music and
you're promoting your music
and you're hoping that you're like
please fans i love you please stick
around for the next show please
still love me yeah you still love me so
my yeah my money if i make money is like
brand
deals or if i write song like my
songwriting has been really good to me
yeah because i write my songs i'm
happening here sorry how do you know
when a song is done
when it's 6 p.m i don't want the check
clear no i yeah i spend one day on a
song
and who are your songwriting heroes
esther dean
um dolly parton yep and
so i'm just um i'm blanking out
who's the girl that wrote everything
like aretha songs uh
uh still alive um i want to say
diane warwick no i love her too but that
the blonde girl do i get no credit for
that diane lauren
would you say warwick diane warwick
she's excellent warlock
carr did it
carol king she's amazing so those ones
hmm um
back in the day hilary duff put out an
album you should check it out
metamorphosis it's great
i'm good and she had her thing opened up
to a poster or i bought a poster from
her
so i was like i want to do on my album
opening a poster
and i even was like i want to be in a
snow globe and i want my signature
because i would look at hillary duff's
signature
all night every night and be like she
really drew that herself
you're in danger to hillary it's so
aggressive
that's my one person is this for her hi
it's a lot i'm like but i lo i i put my
puppy in it bro
above and beyond that looks like a
breeder dog it's
i bought it it's okay
yes i did i saved your life um
okay so the baby is uh are you sick
are you feeling good i'm not excellent
supposed to give birth a lot i think
yeah except
my god we can cut any of it out i'm just
so small
pretend i didn't see your text but i'm
like not only am i like pretty and i say
i'm stupid
you have a tiny pussy tight yes i don't
know how it's going to come out
26 i would hope maybe it's not i don't
know but
like yeah yeah it's all that that um
biking around uh
nantucket chasing my mom explain to me
what's going on
yeah singing sometimes too when you're
singing trying to get a high note you
squeeze your balls
gosh so singers have tighter vaginas yes
they have to guarantee
and buttholes what yeah one culture was
like squeeze your butt
yeah you're like oh my gosh
why i could be like awesome at pushing
him out
you're telling me that singers can't
talk because their vocal cords uh
are injured and they have tight pussies
you're like the perfect woman
i was like how am i single for all those
years i was like where are you
and then i found him and he was like i
gotta marry you but you're gonna do
vaginal yeah i hope yeah i was like um
yo
my doctor was said to me are you gonna
get
what's it called no when you cut the
people
oh oh circumcision she goes yeah what
are we doing are we doing a circumcision
with this baby and i was like
i yeah sure i'd like to push him out
mm-hmm oh
and i she's like no i didn't say
c-section i said so
and i was like she's like i hope you
push him out too
and i was like okay i'm talking about
his dick yeah she was talking about the
penis and i was like i feel like it's so
early
yeah yeah everyone has to do it the
whole point of having your son is like
hope he looks like me
you know yeah but it's i'm torn on the
circumcision thing it's brutal but i
guess they're so young
that it's the same as the umbilical cord
you cut it and they're wounded and they
go home
i'm gonna have to clean up a broken
ripped apart cut dick though
think about that did you think about
that steven
it takes a lot to get me like short
circuit yeah i just broke you
did you think are you circumcised
you had a bad circumcision whenever you
don't have a mic i want you to talk
what do you want to come do it here come
in here well don't scar me
do you wish you didn't do it well it
wasn't your choice but do you wish your
parents didn't do it yeah because i
i do i i just in general just said i in
general think we have to
sit together yeah i think we have to
like embarrassing
i think like i've also you look great
shut up no i mean we just look stupid
i've only seen one in person and it
startled me i just
a non-circumcised one yeah i prefer
uncircumcised
because you can give hand jobs better
because it's just like you know you
there's you mean you can give dry hand
jobs better
you're fucking nasty i'm just saying i'm
like
i don't know how to give hand drops
i mean that was your most nantucket
that was bad we're cancelled i'm like
where's your juice
says buddy congrats he loves me
nailed uh i just i just think that
that when it's uncircumcised like i know
what i'm doing and when it's not
circumcised
there's like i don't know what the
friction to lubricate sometimes they
like that
i guess i know but then i have to ask
and then we have to make it on top
okay okay so then i can use the tears to
lubricate the dick you like
how i do it it's thick and you like the
unknowing of
and then it's like a surprise for you at
the end yeah it's like peek-a-boo
peek-a-boo
it's like it's like a russian nesting
doll you can kind of just keep
finding more and more dicks wow you're
an angel
what does it say about me that i'm
scared no i well it's
it's it's interesting because i know
obviously there's a lot this is gonna
get me in trouble because there's a lot
of like religious uh
there is implications of why we
circumcise but mostly we do it doing it
for looks
for looks and to keep it sanitary but
like
that was kind of uh uh
conceived uh sorry for the pun back when
we didn't have like purell and like
antibacterial
i mean it's it's a it's a little it's a
little bit archaic yeah and then what if
he poops all over himself do i have to
yeah but in that yeah yes
yes every time yes it's your child duh
do you have better things to do but what
if i just had to clean clown but i'm
just
sparkly let me get involved it's also
like
um what is the other thing about um uh
circumcision it does sometimes
numb it does sometimes uh cause numbness
and
are you numb in the baby
uh and please continue yeah i don't know
any of these facts i should have
answered then um the other thing about
it that is fascinating and i don't
remember
they're scarred for life well they are
emotionally i mean it's like a lot of it
is like
you know your first experience your
first pain with a woman usually
if a nurse does it i have a little bit
of a theory going
yeah i'm like they're days like my their
friends
that i um my first major trauma was
being born
that's our first challenge okay you wait
wait did your mom never hold you or love
you uh
she held me but she was busy she didn't
love you she was
uh she did love me this is a heavy
question yeah no i just read a science
where they're like
the most i read a science where
the most trauma a human person can
experience
is if their mother doesn't give them
that connection in the first few months
of their life
but it can also be uh other women too
other women
like other women can do it can do also
they can give you that love
like a village like like i think there's
this thing there's pressure on women now
that it's like that women have that have
nannies that women have helped they feel
like
they feel guilt they feel guilt like i
know so many successful women
so you got love from a nana no i didn't
no i didn't get any love
okay this is a different science okay
this is like i i just i
always feel like i should um say this
because i know so many successful women
that feel
guilt right not being having their child
all day
and going to work and stuff but giving
it to a sister giving it to a mom giving
that's not i need your advice for your
child
okay it's not bad for your you're not a
bad mother because you're
asking for help because kelly's handling
shit let's handle it
i heard their boobs grow milk were you
uh uncircumcised what was your story
oh i was circumcised oh you are
circumcised i was circumcised
and they do say that it's really
traumatic for the baby because like they
they don't wait for anesthesia to like
kick in they just kind of do it and go
but it was not traumatic for me the only
thing that was is apparently i don't
remember this but my mom said
when she was changing me you have to
like put like you know like ointment on
it and stuff
a piece of her hair got caught in it oh
my god and it scabbed over and they had
to pull
the hair out from around it
which apparently was really sad for me
then but totally fine
are you okay yeah i'm talking like a
scar of your mom
did we just lose our manscaped sponsor
oh my god we haven't yet
goodness so you should just feel good
okay do whatever you want
no i won't have my wigs on while i'm
changing like when p when people are
like well i'm circumcising my baby
because
it's it's easier to clean the penis how
hard is it to clean the penis it's like
a thumb how big is it's like how much
surface area i mean just
dump it in the bath dump it in the pool
throw in the pool like what is the
dump it in how hard it is to clean a
tiny baby penis i don't know
i mean i've raised my cousin so i know
yeah like how
it's more to get around really big balls
when they're born yeah they're swollen
yeah i watched my aunt give birth twice
i'm fully prepared
you watched your aunt give birth on
nantucket i visited her during
cramps or during contractions yeah i was
14 years old and they forgot about me in
the corner of the room
i got to watch the whole thing i became
involved i was on her leg counting down
for her and i cut the cord
sign me up and i'm still willing to go
through it
i watched a lady give birth in a creek
on youtube once yes
i saw them
yeah i was like this baby about to drop
on rocks i was like because i've seen
every animal give birth
from those youtube videos yes i go to
okay elephants
we have a creek in our backyard and i
was like she's so earthy though she was
fully naked with long hair and she's
like
i'm mother nature you know yeah that
baby i'm like
epidural help me doctor take you to
[Applause]
i'll get my shots yeah okay
you're the same person i get it um
this is so wild so the oh people are
asking me if i need a night nurse or if
i'm getting a night nurse uh-huh and i
and my mom was like no bitch do it
yourself like she's like i did
everything myself i had three kids do it
yourself
i'm like okay but every la friend of
mine is like
they're older than me and they work on
my team and they're like you need a
night nurse and i'm like i don't know
what to do but i think with my husband i
need a knife i know
i was like cool and somewhere like not
because like
like it doesn't mean you get to sleep
all night they help you because they
um paid because they
have a fat salary no they they train the
baby to eat at regular
hours uh-huh for regular well i mean to
me i
i just think about it it's like it's a
it's a bougie thing you can do it
yourself but you know that growing up
burping i'm sorry i hadn't been blind no
i was burping
the demons had to go no it's like i
think it's more just that
you know i i just think the more women
around a baby the better
you know i think it's like yeah and then
you are able to
you know but it's expensive i mean that
i feel like if i had like a really bad
birth experience i might i would do it
but i don't know i think
daryl's like not that guy he's never
gonna let me wake up alone and take care
of the baby all night long like
he will be there like yeah here we go
every morning he wakes me up because i
think it's good
it's the best thing for the baby that
the mom is rested and not stressed out
and all of that yeah yeah
you know i mean i'm just i'm big on like
um uh
delegating believe it or not um but i do
know one of my best friends had a
lot of trouble breastfeeding and that
was so she had to get a lactation
consultant because she was so stressed
out about that she couldn't lactate and
her nipples were getting so bloody um
not like mine from sex like from trying
to breastfeed
and um it was like really intense and
stressful yeah
stories of women postmating other women
they found online to
shut up and breastfeed their babies
where did you hear this
okay yeah i i'm spooked about the
breastfeeding yeah
that's what you're scared of also i'm
mentally spooked about it
um if i can do it you can do it no it's
like
[Laughter]
i don't know if i'll put this in there
but remember i said all my buttons need
to be pressed for immediate fireworks
yes these are a big part of that in
are you so you you're worried you're
gonna have an orgasm when you're
breastfeeding
daryl's like cut the tape i'm
i'm a little like effed up mentally i
can't have sex right now
or do fireworks because i'm like my
son's insider yeah you're having a
threesome with your child i'm having a
i i'm like wow i used to like i can't
look at him later in life and be like i
came so much when you're inside me
i can't do it i'm sorry my team hates me
that's my mental mess-ups right now i
don't know i don't think i'd be able to
have sex if i was i can't do it
i can't physically i do it we did it
once because i was like
come on megan be a champion and i'm like
oh my god come
on you know commit incest he's also
my mom will kill me he's large so i'm
like you're gonna hit him bro
you're gonna get up there you're gonna
come as i go
like he's gonna don't concuss this
little baby
yeah with that yeah i was like stay
asleep
wild yeah these are all my weird
thoughts
how mad i don't think these are weird i
don't think these are weird i think
everybody has these i think people have
these
people talking about it that's why we
don't talk about it that's why i built
this i'm
freaking talking about these
conversations i feel like if anyone you
can give me these answers
this is so good yeah no so we just have
to also
are you pregnant are you numb because of
the breast surgery i am
numb oh that's such a great question
because that's also huge in my life and
like if i want my face
for you that's like you know when you uh
they did not cut my nipples off okay so
you go around
i had to have uh i basically have had
this surgery like a couple times because
the first time i did it i was so
embarrassed and i was so ashamed i
didn't want to tell anybody
that i did it on my own and i like
googled like breast implants oh my gosh
i went to like beverly hillsboob.net or
something
some like but fake doctor you know um
and
he was like down by the airport like
looking back i should have known this
it was like a plastic surgeon in
torrance california like i should have
known it was like in a kiosk next to a
tanning salon like it should have
um yeah and then so what happened was
the way that he did it he went under the
muscle uh
there's under the muscle breast and
pants and there's over the muscle breast
implants
and the i did under the muscle and
saline
uh which was a mistake saline's no good
i thought it was like healthier because
it's like water and not silicone
like i just i didn't do any research i
didn't ask anybody i was too embarrassed
and then i finally like i talked to a
good friend of mine about it who had had
a breast reduction
and i was like mine are like botched or
messed up or whatever
and then she's like go to this guy it's
not a big deal and i just looked at her
she saved me she didn't judge me or be
like oh you i just thought if you got
plastic surgery on your body like
everyone would hate you and you'd be a
pariah and you'd be maligned and it was
just
you're selling out and you're about
you're not a feminist you're not strong
yeah and i was like um keeping this
crazy secret and she just like oh just
go to this guy it was like it was like
just go pick up your dry cleaning and go
to this guy yeah it was just like a
there's especially boobs i was just so
embarrassed i had so much shame around
them
you know it's like we're shamed for not
looking perfect and then when we try to
make ourselves look better you get the
same for that too yeah like
like i see this with actresses that are
aging in hollywood they're like oh my
god she looks
busted and then when they have had work
done like great well they had worked
oh yeah they go age is tough for her
yeah
and then it looks like they got some
stuff pulled well okay when it wasn't
yeah yeah ugly what yeah what what
option do we guys just look better
and better we also aren't trying to fuck
you yeah
like you don't need to dark we're good
you know so um uh so yeah so then
um the what he does is he goes through
the nipple so i have a little i've i've
lost a little feeling
under the nipples but not crazy i'm not
a nipple person that's not my like
it wasn't mine then it became very much
mine interesting
i know it's like people change
interesting people
people change yes so that's like a big
scarify
yeah i don't think i don't like the
breastfeeding i'm spooked the
breastfeeding
and what if they ruin that fun for me
what if my sweet baby
this like everybody steals your orgasm
people say like when you're
breastfeeding it's just like which
nipple is less bloody today
and i was like oh my god am i gonna be
scarred and be like daryl stay away from
me like yeah
and then are you like completely because
i have a
uh when kate upton was on the podcast
she had trouble breastfeeding which is
crazy because her breasts
are pendulous perfect and
uh it has nothing to do with breast size
or whatever but she
um had to just use formula and she was
like there was so much shame around
using formula and not being able to
produce
for your child yeah i heard hillary
talking about that on the hair oh that's
right i was like that must be such a
mind
mess up like a mind fuck of like like
you're failing as a woman yeah you're
failing
one thing you're designed to do
biologically i told my mom on the way
here i told her that story i was like
she loves talking about pregnancy so i'm
going to talk to her about that
and my mom's like oh also tell her when
they breastfeed
there's something attached with your
uterus so you feel like you're being
punched in the stomach while you're
breastfeeding at the same time
oh because that process shrinks your
uterus back to normal
whoa so when everyone's like i lost all
my weight because i just breastfed it
out it's like no your body is like going
back to normal but that shit
hurts and no one talks about it they
also have like it's matt alright
18 facts of like no one talks about this
shit what else
abs they split they split they tear open
well beyonce
homecoming didn't she i remember in the
homecoming documentary she was like uh
uh because i didn't know if she had a
cesarean or not i don't know
what if a dart just hit me in the neck
um no but yeah she was talking she
talked about it in homecoming calm down
the beehive just stopped yeah um uh
that yeah her abs she had to reattach
them with some exercise
yeah yeah and they don't tell you back
in the day back in the day they were
like make sure you smoke zig so you stay
skinny
and then before after that they're like
don't work out because it's so dangerous
for you and the baby
and like make sure you're just sitting
all day no that's worse
so i got a trainer who works with
pregnant people
and she taught me how like what you want
to make sure is that your abs don't
split early on
so you don't see a fist come out way too
soon
because that that gives women like the
ultimate fupa for the rest of their life
and you can't get it back is that on
youtube like why is it
why isn't this not and i freaked out i
should do a video with her
well my trainer yeah she's a miracle
like like she checks me every day of my
abs like when i push i'm like there's no
abs she's like you have abs squeeze
and so i show her and she's like okay
great these are together these are
together these are together
she's like we're perfect and like they
will go out a little bit during your
pregnancy but you don't want to see
you don't want it to go over here right
so you do certain exercises to make sure
you're out yeah but you
you can't do like a full crunch we do
like planks and we do safe workouts
where
i'm like in a dog position what am i in
for um are we still talking about the
babies
every day you're in uh i'm on my knees
in my hands okay
okay and it's like cat cow whatever but
i pull in my
i pull in my abs for like 10 seconds and
hold uh-huh
and that's how i work out my abs like no
one tells you this
no one told me no one tells you this was
passed so
also gestational diabetes what's that oh
i mean i know but what you scared no the
scary thing i didn't know
you get it's like diabetes in your
placenta i don't know it's terrifying
and i was my i like made a joke i was
like oh by the way my mom had diabetes
for like
a month when she was pregnant but it
went away and she's like oh
let's check you for that just in case
and i was like nah it's not a big deal
and she's like let's check
my blood sugar was through the roof and
they're like hey we're gonna have to do
the long testing which was
four hours of blood testing all on
fasting drinking their nasty juice
and just staying at the hospital for
four hours like every hour
go back up and get my blood tested and
i'm like i don't want gestational
diabetes right now like
i'm not even halfway through my
pregnancy and it's like the scariest
thing ever and then you wait a week
to see if you have it or not and i'm
googling like what's it like living with
gestational diabetes and it's like
having full bone diabetes while you're
pregnant so you're starving and you want
to eat everything and you're like nope i
have to
be in control write down everything tap
cut my finger and make sure
my blood's good so scary and then i went
full keto and went like
no sugar right before those blood tests
and they were like you passed and i was
like
like so relieved but also now i'm
rattled
so scared so i got a trainer and i went
full keto after that week
of crying of like do i have gestational
diabetes how do women do this and it's
genetic the fact that women used to do
they didn't bro
people had just said well they died yeah
they died and like
and it's like well i was like what's the
worst that could happen i mean we're not
designed to really survive
childbirth we're and i was like well
what's the worst that like what's the
bad part about this they're like well
your baby could be ginormous and you
have to cut them out
like c-section and i was like i don't
want a giant baby
like and they could have diabetes
i was like i wanna and i don't want to
push out a 10 pounder
my mom did that with her first kid and
it was a vacuum they vacuumed him out
couldn't breathe for the first hour on
his own it's crazy he's alive he's good
they broke my collarbone to get me out
no way they broke my collarbone to get
me out and they blacked my eye
and they cut my cheek with a scalpel it
was a very you've been through
it you came out fighting bro they broke
your collarbone and then cut your dick
off
yeah and then they and he hit me in the
eye with the back of his hand the doctor
he's not a doctor anymore by the way he
never was a doctor
i don't i don't think he was suspended
at the time either
they had to use his collarbone to get
out supposed to do because they can
puncture babies long but they sure did
how do they do it with like a hammer his
finger like that what's your age
29. god benton
or benton it's uh so much is starting to
make sense but yeah all this pregnancy
stuff
my sweet manager over here she's like
gonna have a baby later after me and
she's like
this is great for me to learn so no
i mean someday sorry to your boyfriend
what um and they
also they don't tell you that you're not
every woman's water breaks they say only
like 10 percent of women's water
breaking a lot of women
uh their birth plan gets fucked up
because they saw in movies
my mom got popped sorry like they popped
her water for her
because she never could break hers or
never broke wow yeah
and i was like cool that's probably me i
was like do you feel that like what's
that like
i just fee i just i'm a friend of mine
lucy punch described
uh uh because i was like describe the
pain like i want to understand i know
that we were designed to handle the pain
and like you know your brain gets
flooded with oxytocin right afterwards
so that we
yeah you black it out we black it out so
that we'll have more kids right we're
biologically designed to forget about
that
yeah we'll keep reproducing because
otherwise we'd never do it again
yeah but she said it was like um she
said it was like
what are the things that you drive that
roll over things on asphalt
cars no steamroller
a steamroller she's like it's like it
was like steamrolling all my organs wow
i felt like every like my ribs were
breaking yeah my ribs were breaking in
every and i just it was like
the it was like the clearest description
of pain i've heard
yeah putting on spanx yes amen
[Laughter]
yeah my aunt broke her collarbone when
she pushed out one of them
you can break bones bro it's like the
worst pain
but i in my head i'm like okay i do that
thing where i'm like if i can get
through this i can do anything
okay sorry it's just this isn't about me
right now it's become like
way like she did this a lot about you i
just had to make it about me i'm just
wow dude yeah and then epidural i'm
gonna be numb dude
you're gonna be chilling i'm gonna be
shaking
and then okay so we
want to talk about the christmas out we
i know we have to let you go at some
point are you going to write a song
about your baby when it's born
i'm writing a full lullaby album for me
baby
oh my god and then on my christmas song
i got a song called my kind of present
that was originally just like a cute
love song that i want to be like a big
christmas song
but i turned it into you're my kind of
present and i like pat my tummy
but you're gonna have um we're gonna
dethrone mariah carey
there's no such thing bro i mean you got
the one song
but it's the biggest song of all time
and can can you explain i think i know
why but why
as someone that understands music oh
it's uh
it's just easy to sing along to it's
great melodies
sounds classic timeless yeah you could
play in a hundred years from now people
be like wow
what a two yeah you know it's one of
those it's it's just
it's just incred it's just like why is
it it's so addictive yeah it's like
really catchy so i try to write all my
melodies to be hon like a lot of dads
will tell me
i can't go to sleep at night because i'm
just listening to your melodies over and
over again i'm singing your songs back
and that's like my goal
um uh i love christmas music so much
because my christmases were always bad
so i would listen to christmas music
throughout the year like christmas music
is just
i had to like do emdr around christmas
because i
it was like grew up alcoholic home like
christmas is family can be hard for i
mean it's hard
all of these are hard people the best or
the worst either the best or the worst
and like as we get older we have to make
our
pick our chosen family and boundaries
around family and figure out the way to
make holidays not be a nightmare
and christmas music was like the one
thing they can't take away from you yeah
you're in your room and you have your
christmas music and like
and you can do it three days after like
the second it's on it's christmas day
yeah yeah like december one i'm like
christmas album like the day after
thanksgiving really i start playing
christmas music in the house all the
time
but i see i try to make sure i have a
song for everyone on the album
and i got one for you it's called
christmas got me blue
and it's like this pop pop anthem that
you can dance to but it's like
it's even if i feel sad fuck it it's
exciting
yeah i got you really sad but you did
that other christmas song a while ago
i'll be home for christmas
i wrote that by myself and now that song
thank you so much i like produced it in
this room by myself and was like
nobody's going to hear this
people still come up to me they're like
i'll be home and i hear it in the malls
all the time
not now because corona but before oh
good i was like wow
it's wild because um uh i i love like
christmas music that you like rap
presents do yeah
yeah it's not like like i but i do love
emotional christmas songs my favorite
christmas song of all time
is tori amos covering little drummer boy
oh it's excellent and melissa etheridge
did
i think that joni mitchell war is over
the war is over
uh melissa etheridge shit awards over
wow you have a huge heart yes
that was a big one those are from moshi
yeah very very
profound yeah deep i've never like
connected so deeply with the drummer boy
so i didn't do that yeah before but
toriyama's singing and it was like she
was big for me
it's like i also pick songs like i know
where my voice is i know i'm not like
interesting i'm not the big voice that's
like let's
scream and hit these high notes so i'm
like i'm going to stick with like
white christmas yeah like honestly jumpy
and i'll stay down here
i'll show you where i can try i don't
want to take it i don't but i'm not
going to come in being like
oh no
i'm picking the easy fun happy go lucky
like rudolph you know so don't be
concerned
i almost did it i love that one that's
his favorite song i love it that's my
favorite song are we the same human
being
it's really it's enough i'm sorry it's
enough i know i know
i'm sorry i'm sorry i knew what happened
okay this has happened to every podcast
trust me
you know everyone's just using me to get
to benton and i frankly don't blame them
um i'm just going to mysteriously die in
like a instagram influence accident
and then benton um uh i was going to
show you that okay
millie vanilli we've been through a lot
this has been a journey you know my
whole sex life that no one else knows
so dope it's so dumb i'm a hero
you are a legend a hero because my
generation i want to give a master
we didn't talk about all this stuff and
we all felt weird and ashamed i talked
to everyone about it
and like our generation didn't do that
we didn't talk about it so we all just
thought we were weird and deformed and
gross
and and that was all true that's sad
it's important to move forward and
failures and we poop like it's just yeah
yeah yeah this is what oh oh this is the
one thing i'm gonna say to you i have
mothering advice for you oh yay
that i learned um uh
a big no-no okay that parents do
uh that cause shame for their babies
in a in a very sort of like deep
subconscious way
is when you change diapers you go ah
you shouldn't do that people do it all
the time and then they learn
like my genitals are gross yeah and my
poop is gross
my poop is i'm grown they don't know
well babies don't know
i couldn't poop in public for like years
i feel fine and i feel
fine you know what i feel like i
remember anything or like a real thing
i feel like i remember when my mom would
put tylenol up my butt when she would
change my diaper
yeah i like no at like a later age when
i was like oh like
my last my last few diapers i feel like
i remember the feeling of being like no
mom no
[Laughter]
those are the things i think there's a
few memories and that makes sense
my mom used to throw up
like that she's not like changing baby
are you going to give your baby a
whoopin no i don't i don't believe in
that
um i love dr phil so he says never hit
your kids
he said i want you to enjoy your life
yeah yeah yeah he's like there's no
reason to hit a kid and
and i believe that and i never got
spanked once when i was 13.
she should have done it you'll never but
you'll never forget that
and every time i see her i thank her i'm
not joking i i was angry what did you do
i mean i called her a hooker
but no it was actually it was dope
i'm pro like you know i was
out of line i was a danger to myself and
i was like stealing how old were you
i think i was i i i just i just
i was like okay if you're like 18. i
just thought i was no i just thought i
was 13 but i think i was actually more
like 11.
okay at the time of the session and i
was like and she was
like dating men after the divorce of my
dad i thought
you've had all the hards you know it's
fine it got it's good it makes sense
good
good i'm grateful for it it's like help
me you're a good person
like because that um and uh it makes me
like
relatable um none of it's true um
and so uh uh i'm glad she did it because
it was so
fucking disrespectful and i was such a
punk for doing that
and it was she was never violent with me
she was just like oh that was your one
and done
yeah one at she and i was like uh
because she was like out late like on a
date which she should have been doing
she didn't date for like six years after
the divorce she finally
got mama she finally did the best thing
for her and went on
on a date with two kids and you called
her and i was like
because you're out last night because
you're a hooker and she was like
boom and i like hit the floor and uh
it sucked at the time but i deserved it
wow i used to paddle kids
at my school that's why that's why i
don't understand how you're 29.
you your story sounds like you're 48. i
know but i'm in a town that i mean there
was 11 of us in my class
oh and it was like southern what were
you yeah
[Music]
that's so wrong i don't know so hot and
my favorite thing that dr phil said
so huh my favorite thing that daddy phil
says um
is catch me outside yeah but is uh
oh never involve children in adult
issues
which is like so key and i see adults do
it with their kids and i'm like
rule number one take that shit outside
and never uh lie to your kids because
they always know
so you can't there's no every no one's
getting away with anything so yeah
something i remember
um like if you guys are fighting or
whatever which you don't obviously but
you know what i mean
at anyone listening like you don't and
then they go what's wrong why are you
screaming and like oh we were just play
acting
like kids no you know we had a
disagreement and we were working it out
and i lost you
whatever the bad news is just tell them
they can handle it yeah but if you lie
to them
they start to doubt their own reality
because it's too traumatic to the psyche
to think that their caretakers that are
responsible for their survival have
flaws i love this shit
so i love this shit so what they do is
they go well i must be
bad i'm crazy and they stop um trusting
their reality
that's why we're gonna be excellent
parents yeah do jiu-jitsu
that's where it is like why are you guys
fighting we're not we're doing jiu-jitsu
no it's a lie and then you don't tell
them that you never tell them to stop
crying
oh that's a good one yeah well yeah yeah
yeah correct and let them figure out
like because they're trying to
get something out of it so you can
either ignore them if they're crying
and let them learn to self soothe but no
like stop crying stop crying
yeah yeah you just look at them and go
like oh you're crying this is um robert
green and i were talking about this
that's awesome if you're saying like
you're crying you're sad i've been there
i totally get it i understand that
sounds hard like their
basic funnel fundamental need is to be
seen and understood
right so telling someone to stop crying
is just when i see parents in fucking
public places you're like
stop crying this is gonna make it just
um exacerbates the situation because
it's so much worse
it's so tough if you're just like a kid
and go like oh and when you're like not
a parent and you're trying to help
and they're like you just feel so stupid
and they're like you don't know what
it's like to have a kid i'm like i don't
but like
i know that's wrong yeah i know that
shit is wrong yeah
yeah and it's hard because it's so hard
but that's why i can't wait to have this
because then i could be like here's my
advice
i'm a mom bitch like here's my
kids have kids like they're not healed
yet yeah you know they didn't get what
they needed
exactly they're passing on bad people oh
my god
yeah when you're like like let's go to
therapy yeah all of us will go together
yeah
yeah and then just refuse it's a thing
obsessed you're gonna be the best mom
i think so no i know so my discipline
benjamin's gonna be the best mom to my
child
because i when i worked at the mall the
kids would come in and they would like
start you know throwing things off
counters and acting a fool and the moms
would be like you're really hurting
mommy's feelings when you act like that
you're really hurting my feelings and
i'm like
you have to do something yeah um i think
daryl and i love we talked about
hitting like a hitting no we've talked
about saying
this like this line um
i would say to adults too i feel like
it's so powerful just being like
it's all right buddy i'm just
disappointed you know like one of those
because it's like oh my god like my
favorite person my mom or my dad is
disappointed in me yeah it's like i
don't know i feel like that's a
nice subtle way of being like it's okay
buddy next time just do it different i'm
just like really disappointed yeah dude
and then adults would hate that and then
also they just do everything you do
yeah you can't have a dissonance or an
incongruence you know they copy you
there's like whatever you do so like why
is my kids screaming
and they all scream and they also need
to test us they're animals like we we
we we call them humans which is fine but
that word is like
it confuses people it's like they're
testing us yeah generally i mean they're
constantly trying to test if they're
safe test if they're safe so yeah
parents are just like oh my kid's a
nightmare it's like no he's just testing
you because of your
weakness yeah he constantly has to test
you and test you and see where the line
is because they're just trying to figure
out if you can protect them
yeah that's all they want to know and
then when you can't they feel unsafe and
then they get even freaked out
freaked out wow you're my bible
there's a great book uh it's the worst
name
for a great book and if you uh order it
online you might end up in megan's law
but it's called the wonder of boys and
they're like delicious about like
like the lord of the flies like what
they need to do to test you and test you
and test you it's just like a really big
part
the one your voice i'll send it to you
but it's like we conflate bat we we
pathologize bad behavior when they're
just testing you
yeah yeah yeah and every day they need
to wake up and go they're when when kids
are being dicks they're saying am i safe
now am i safe now am i safe now that's
crazy
that's it that's great and then you're
going no relax and they're like great
yeah
yeah keep testing you because you're not
showing you're not yeah
i don't all they're doing is saying i
don't feel safe daryl's obsessed with
his books he's been reading all those
yeah he gives me like great advice
i just watched dr phil all day long so
that's my like
parenting place where i'm surprised he
hasn't been canceled
i know he's still there he's awesome um
uh yeah i've definitely i love watching
crazy people
like yeah with their fucked up families
i'm like
like teach me anything i can't believe
she would do that it's like the best
reality tv public fight do you ever go
oh my god
you and me need to have a whole night
yeah i go public freakouts
or i'll be like i can watch them for
races assholes and i'm like how are
these people the ones that are
in starbucks screaming at the at the
barista dude
i could watch them on a loop and like
now there's a whole new karen's
there's a whole new society of videos
that's up there every day
there should not be that many videos of
people yelling like that and there's i
mean there's months and why are they
white blonde girls they make us look bad
ruin it for us i love public free count
it makes
i get uncomfortable i cringe but it and
like why and everyone's like why do you
like watching sad stories on dr phil and
i'm like
because if i'm feeling sad about
something i'm like well at least at
least my
mom didn't fuck my brother like yeah we
had dude we had at least
something horrible i loved everything
that was my
18 year like when i go 18 when i turn 18
which i never did
i'm gonna take my dad and we're gonna go
to jerry springer and that's gonna be my
best birthday ever
like that was my goal in life to hit
that was like the peak that was the
grammys so that was
that was an insane i watched that all
the time that's the one where they're
like why do you watch this that was like
that was like sports for women yes it's
so good you know
it's like oh we've been hooking up for
weeks but you didn't know i'm a man
i'm like hold on and then jerry would
you like to get the whole time he died
he goes what how could they do that it's
awesome he'd be like he was sleeping
with you one girl was on there and she
was like
she's like proud because she was like
800 pounds and she was like so i was
eating and he was like
you were she's like i know surprise
surprise i was like
this is so messed up that was like the
first
like i don't know i think there's
something like what was that like what
is it that what is that the first like
reality tv i mean yeah reality tv it was
like it was like
the first oh people who aren't in
hollywood and they're always more
entertaining
than anything we could write up yeah
humans are scary yes humor
what scares me the most besides death is
humans yes human beings
they're so terrible they're wild but i
love watching them freak out i love
watching him be crazy at a distance
what happened to jerry springer i think
he's he hosts something else
i think that i roasted him on the trump
roast wasn't he on the trump roast
he was kind of a dick yeah amazing
yeah he like reminds me of my dad he
looks like him oh buddy
yeah but no yeah we loved that show
that's all that played on the east coast
you know i unleash very awkwardly what i
end these very awkwardly
oh are you about to break up with me
it's 5 30. like i just oh shut up i feel
like i have you i haven't even had to
pee
you're going to go into labor if we
continue this i want him to be kicking
i'm so excited for pat
you think about batgirl come on i'm cool
charlie pat um
bobby brown
it is a white name but it's not that
white whitney is a unisex name
yes it is um
it's a ha ha two syllables it's all give
you
razzle dazzle oh close
no it's not forwards
monty that's cute
damn it okay you guys guess her name in
the comments
engagement um i love you
uh christmas album available now
don't fuck up your christmas by not
buying it you'd be an idiot
i love you what a dream i love you we
could be friends
i think we're friends if you want i
don't have many so this is cool
dude i feel like we're going to be
friends i have distance i didn't know
how this was going to go because i don't
know anything about me oh my god they
were like she's so obsessed with you
i was like okay she knows all about you
i was like
no i just music people scare me because
uh it's a world that i don't know and
there's so much like
there's i get that comedian scare
community and scare me yeah oh that that
and the whole
label of them of like they're the
saddest people yeah oh my god how do i
cheer her up you know yeah yeah
you can't how do i go in making her
laugh
that's so funny how do i
how do i get her to not commit suicide
during the whole time hanging by a
thread
yeah no it's it's it's music people just
scare me there's
it's so intimidating because music is so
um uh there's just such a larger than
lifeness about what you guys do and it's
a talent that i don't under
it's a creepy talent that i don't
understand
and i don't know how to manipulate or
like
you know it's um it just
you don't get a lot you don't get i
think i don't know why
like for actors big actors they're not
as famous as musicians
i don't get that but no but more
comedians no because no no athletes and
musicians are more famous than anybody
why because the song i
and we associate it it's like we fuck to
music we like
daily memories like we get you know what
i mean and it makes us do this where
shows make
us go like this isn't that funny like
you don't you're not judging
you know oh it's like your fun time yeah
soundtrack and if you like an artist you
like love them because you're willing to
sit there
and actors you don't know their names
you don't know that yeah so you're like
that guy from that thing
what's his name he's been in so many
things that's me yeah every person also
music is something we can listen to over
and over and we enjoy it every time
like if i tell you a joke three times
you're like i got it yeah oh
it hinges on surprises
a lot of times they're like this isn't
the new stuff i wanted you to have it's
like that's so much pressure it's a
trickier
thing but yeah musicians just scare me a
little bit i think definitely the
generation before you there was such a
machine
around them and there was such a
question sort of they were such
zombies and so many people around them
enabling them and stuff that it was just
like musicians like
just the ones that i had met and known i
was just like like we can be people now
you're like human beings now yeah yeah
they like that now so it's fun like you
can like make eye contact with you yeah
yeah yeah yeah
now i was like oh i could be on tv
people like yeah but you don't like wear
sunglasses inside
bro is this intimidating though it's
full weight it's definitely intense i
walked i
saw myself in the car and i was like i
look too good so
i'm gonna scare people no i've seen your
shoes you don't look too yeah i got my
uggs in my
my compression size what is that's my
uggs those are nice
oh it's got a thing on the back fancy
shit
oh i bought them myself
i wear these all day long fucking gross
i'm dirty but it's okay okay so i'm
going to go
buy a red box so i can watch this yes
how do i go get an old
waffle man yes just download it
websites download it to make her
siblings so
famous that they turn against her wait
no support my child
support my unborn child and stream
myself money off of twitter
this is i liked your stand up in 2016
when you were like please assholes on
youtube watch this there so i can get
point 10 cents for this
oh yeah that's when it was like all i do
is work and i don't make any money don't
make money it was like all i do is sell
tickets and i don't i'm like i'm kidding
i get the broker i am like the deal
that's the thing is this working because
your overhead
it gets harder and the way the business
change they're like no no no yeah yeah
yeah you had your moment yeah and you're
a woman and you're like lucky
yeah so we're just gonna pay you a
quarter of what we pay the guys because
they don't they
ask questions and you don't yeah they
don't wear wigs like i should be so
lucky to break even on them
i love you i love you i'll leave i'll
leave i love you thanks for watching
smash that subscribe
i could be a youtuber
you